momentum sometimes thinking too much can
destroy your momentum Tom Watson my
condo is a total mess there are clothes
all over the living room floor my fridge
is almost empty today was the first time
I shaved in a week Evan what the heck
are you doing something big something
I'm excited about something that has
given me huge momentum I'm not making
things public yet but the teachable
lesson today is when you have momentum
stay in it for as long as possible
running the business is hard most of the
time you're just trying to keep up and
stay afloat that's why momentum is
important momentum is where the magic
happens when you've got momentum you're
getting things done quickly things that
might have taken you weeks do are flying
off your checklist you feel the energy
that it brings you you feel like your
business idea will work even though
everyone's telling you it won't if you
stop now you'll kill your momentum this
is where so many entrepreneurs make a
mistake you get a great idea something
that really excites you and you tell
yourself you'll do tomorrow or next week
and then you never do it if you're
excited by something take action right
away immediately send an email to
someone make a phone call visit a store
or library to do some research and do as
much as you can while you're in the zone
because that work will be gold for you
the work you do in one week when you're
feeling the momentum will be more
valuable than months of your usual work
push everything else meetings calls
emails and so on your usual daily
routine can wait this is too important
pay attention to it and don't let your
momentum slip away Evan this kind of
lifestyle isn't sustainable you're right
I'm a neat freak I hate clothes on the
floor I've got to eat I need some food
in the fridge at some point I'm gonna
need to get a great night's sleep again
this isn't sustainable for me or you
being in the zone isn't sustainable
either I don't know anyone who wakes up
at
single day in the zone if your passion
but what you're doing and really believe
in it then that's a fantastic start but
you still don't wake up every day in the
zone so stay in a zone as long as you
can and when you fall out of it go back
to your regular routine there's a huge
difference between being a workaholic
wearing down your health and driving
your friends and family away and
maximizing time spent in the zone when
you have momentum all the best progress
I've made and all of my businesses have
come from being in the zone and using
the momentum I had it's totally worth it
believe